the New York Daily News fires half its
staff and every Democrat vows to help
Millennials virtue signal on issues that
don't matter and president Trump both
loves tariffs and also wants to somehow
fix the impact of the tariffs it's all
confusing i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
president Trump's Twitter feed is a
cornucopia cornucopia veritable
cornucopia of joy and issues and uh
sometimes it appears that the president
is getting high off his own supply when
it comes to Twitter and we will go
through his Twitter feed which is just
lit as the children say these days but
first I want to get to how you can make
your resume better so let's be real
about this whatever job you're currently
holding tired break it's you employees
but in five years you will probably not
be holding that job and it's not because
I didn't get fired it's gonna be because
your resume is gonna get better and
you're gonna want a better job or you're
gonna want to raise or you gonna let's
start a side business well the best way
to do that is by heading over to skill
share and talking with my friends over
there skill share is an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more you
can take classes in social media
marketing and illustration and data
science mobile photography creative
writing you name it they've got a course
on the top by an expert these courses
are like 45 minutes and they're really
fantastic top-notch stuff whether you're
trying to deepen your professional skill
set or start that side hustle or explore
new passions Skillshare is for you I've
taken classes in social media marketing
and yes watercolours because some of us
have to relax in our off hours
that's what skills share can do for you
go check it out right now join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners you get two months
of Skillshare for just 99 cents that's
right Skillshare is offering ben shapiro
show listeners two months of unlimited
access to over 20,000 classes for just
99 cents to sign up go to skill shared
comm slash Shapiro that skill shared
comm Shapiro to start those two months
right now Skillshare comm slash Shapiro
again 99 cents for those two months when
you get a subscription go check it out
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro
alright so every morning I wake up and I
prepare for the show and I have to
figure out what am I going to talk about
today and then president Trump does my
show prep for me because he goes on
Twitter and that's what happened this
morning when the president decided to
tweet about tariffs and here's what the
president tweeted and it is pretty
spectacular he tweeted tariffs are the
greatest exclamation point either a
country which has treated the United
States unfairly on trade negotiates a
fair deal and order gets hit with
tariffs it's as simple as that and
everybody's talking remember we are the
piggy bank scare quotes that's being
robbed all will be great capital G Wow
there's a lot there to unpack okay so we
could talk about the back
are not in fact the greatest the last
people who thought the tariffs were the
greatest were a couple of guys named
Smoot and Harley they were responsible
for a tariff regime that ended up
lengthening the Great Depression by
probably eight years so tariffs are not
in fact the greatest specifically
because they're artificially increasing
the price of products that you pay for
on the shelves and they are also
artificially increasing the part the
prices of inputs for American companies
they also draw a retaliatory tariffs so
that means that American companies can't
ship their products overseas to sell
them how do I know all this well it's
not Theory according to Bloomberg
harley-davidson has now cut his profit
margin forecast for this year because of
tariffs this is breaking today
harley-davidson has cut its forecast for
profit margin by an amount that suggests
it's finding a way to cope with the
damage done by President Donald Trump's
trade war operating margin this year
will drop to about nine point five
percent that's a midpoint of a range the
Milwaukee based manufacturer gave in a
statement on Tuesday citing the expected
impacts of tariffs they had been
projecting a margin of roughly 10
percent so this is a little bit lower
than their normal margins and they're
also moving some of their factories to
Europe also whirlpool has now announced
that they are lowering their estimates
for this year the maker of home
appliance has said rising raw material
costs hurt results in three out of four
of its regional markets in the second
quarter including North America Asia and
it's struggling Europe Middle East and
Africa division the only region where it
didn't cite input cost inflation was in
Latin America which faced its own
problems in the second quarter according
to Bloomberg including a Brazilian
trucker strikes according to chief
executive officer mark Robert Bitzer he
said our annual steel contracts and
hedging contracts with our base metals
give us some protection but do not
insulate us from these more material
trends so in other words all of those
manufacturing jobs that President Trump
wants to protect are actually being hurt
by the tariffs that he loves and thinks
are the greatest technically by the way
Muhammad Ali is the greatest I mean we
all know that but according to president
trump tariffs are in fact the greatest
also I do love that everybody is talking
I didn't realize that that was a school
of economics now the everybody's talking
school of economics and I was also under
the impression that everybody was
talking about the bird because of course
the bird is the word
but the fact that the President of the
United States continues to tweet out
about the stuff suggests that he doesn't
actually know what he's talking about we
are not a piggy bank being robbed again
for the 1,000th time when I make a trade
with you
you are not robbing me robbing me
involves you using force or deception in
order to take products or services or
money from me without my knowledge or
without my consent that is not what
happens in a trade if I have a trade
deficit with you that's because I gave
you money and you gave me a product I
have a trade deficit with lots of people
over all I do okay ask fiscally that's
true of the United States as well but I
have a trade deficit with my dry
cleaners I have a trade deficit with our
nanny I have a trade deficit with our
gardener I have a trade deficit with the
with the local restaurants around here a
pretty massive trade deficit with the
local restaurants around here that
doesn't mean the solution is for me to
stop shopping at those restaurants or
stores at the grocery and instead
artificially increase costs now how do
we know that this is actually having an
impact I know there are a lot of people
right now are shaking their heads no if
Trump says tariffs are great it's
because tariffs are great because he's
making tariffs great again or somesuch
if this were the case then why exactly
is the president now announcing that he
is going to be providing aid to farmers
so according to Politico today the Trump
administration is planning to ease fears
of a trade war by announcing later on
Tuesday billions of dollars in aid to
farmers hurt by tariffs according to two
sources familiar with the plan the
administration's plan will use two
commodities support programs in the farm
bill as well as the agricultural
department's broad authority to
stabilize the agricultural economy
during times of turmoil the plan has
been in the works for months it seeks to
ensure US farmers and ranchers a key
constituency for President Trump and
Republicans don't bear the brunt of an
escalating trade fight with China the
European Union and other major economies
as the administration pursues an
aggressive course to rebalance America's
trade relationships Trump's move to slap
tariffs on imports from some of
America's largest trading partners have
prompted retaliation against US farm
goods like pork beef soybeans sorghum
and a range of fruits so it's happening
is that President Trump decided he
wanted to tariffs cars for example and
these countries that we are now
terrifying have decided they're going to
tariffs America and extra cultural
exports which means that our farmers
don't have any place to ship their goods
which are now withering on the vine so
now President Trump is going to borrow
from the future in order to pay off
those farmers this is exactly what FDR
did this is exactly FDR's policy FDR's
policy from 1933 all the way until the
war began in 1941 was this policy the
policy was that we are going to leverage
tariffs against people who are screwing
us in trade wars we're gonna
those trade Wars and then we were going
to somehow make up for all the farmers
who were losing money by artificially
boosting prices now if the are ones how
virus to actually regulate farmers and
force farmers to actually burn off their
excess grain and supply in order to
boost prices so he provided them with
all sorts of subsidies and then he also
regulated up them up the wazoo see
didn't have an oversupply of grain this
led to a very famous case at the Supreme
Court called Wickard V filburn when a
guy was growing grain for his own
consumption and the federal government
said you have to burn off the grain for
your own consumption because you're
artificially lowering the price of grain
you're creating too much grain it's
lowering the price in the global market
because you are eating that grain
instead of buying it from somebody else
and the Supreme Court idiotically under
pressure from FDR found that the federal
government could actually regulate your
ability to grow grain in your own
backyard for your own use somehow this
impact in interstate commerce Trump's
policy here is FDR policy and this is
one of the problems with the areas where
the president has sole control the
Constitution of the United States does
not delegate tariff power to the
President of the United States it
delegates tariff power to the
legislature now originally the
legislature delegated tariff power the
President of the United States because
they wanted the presidency they wanted
the executive branch to lower tariffs
and they figured that it would be easier
to have a president who could
unilaterally lower tariffs than it would
be to have a legislature that has a
lower tariffs by Fiat by legislation
well the problem is once you give a lot
of power to the executive the executive
can use it however he wants so the
presidents of the United States can
simply play with the tariff rights this
is what FDR did in the 1930s it was a
disaster area and Donald Trump is doing
it now none of this is particularly good
policy and and the president should
reverse this as fast as possible larry
cudlow somewhere is spinning in his
grave wait he's still alive right okay
larry cudlow somewhere is spinning in
his office but all the people in the in
the administration who are pro
free-trade are looking at tweets like
this and thinking why would the
president undercut his own strong
economy with this sort of foolishness
and you can't you can't hope that the
economy holds out forever when you are
taking measures that are designed to
tamp down the economy tariffs are not in
fact great and the president is going to
find that out the hard way if he
continues along this path now the all of
this has some impact on the generic
congressional ballot right now it looks
like the Democrats do have the momentum
again in the congressional races the
president's approval ratings as I
discussed yesterday
continue to be very high
but the congressional races are starting
to open up in favor of Democrats at
least on the generic ballot and part of
that is because the president is
unpopular if as I said yesterday the
Democrats are going to climb back into
this thing if the if the Republicans are
going to climb back into this thing it's
going to be a reliant on the Democrats
overstepping their boundaries
fortunately there is a good shot of that
the the I think solid critiques that
could be leveraged against policies of
the Trump administration of gone by the
wayside in favor of completely unhinged
insane sort of critiques so kirsten
gillibrand leads the way she suggests
that it's time for the Democratic Party
to abolish ice if she wants to ensure
that the Democrats never win back
Congress is a pretty solid way to do it
right here I think we should get rid of
ice we should separate out to missions
and do the anti-terrorism mission the
national security mission and then on
the other side make sure you're doing
looking at immigration as a humanitarian
issue these are civil issues these are
families look at as the economic engine
that it is that immigration is our
strength
it is our diversity is what makes this
country and our economy so strong okay
so she wants to abolish ice that's
obviously going to be a very unpopular
point of view but she's nothing compared
to Andrew Cuomo so Andrew Cuomo wants to
run for president of the United States
which would be amazing he'd be the first
inanimate object ever to be presidents
of the United States Andrew Cuomo that'd
be like an actual incredible thing I
used to think that Chris Cuomo was the
dummer of the Cuomo brothers and it
turns out that Andrew is actually the
dummer of the Cuomo brothers and also
the least charming which is pretty
amazing I mean like I really didn't
think that was possible
yesterday Andrew Cuomo was speaking and
he said that President Trump had
declared a jihad he'd put a jihad on you
he declared a jihad on the on immigrants
to the United States yeah this kind of
language is definitely gonna win
Democrats a lot of friends and
supporters what they've done at the
border is an example of it what they've
done in Puerto Rico and they are on a
jihad to deport as many people as they
can who they believe are not in the
United States legally okay so they are
on a jihad first of all I would just
like to point out that if a Republican
ever said that any politician was on a
jihad against anything people would
immediately call them an Islamophobe
right you're only allowed to use the
word jihad when you are specifically
referring
to an internal struggle because that's
what it means according to Quran okay so
guys get that right and then Andrew but
Andrew Cuomo says the Trump is on a
jihad against immigrants yeah that's
that's the way you're gonna win over all
those people in the middle of the
country who are attempting to cope with
falling wages in particular industries
if you really think that any of that is
going to win back the the base of Trump
support to the Democratic side of the
aisle you have to be crazy in the second
I want to talk about the elitism that is
evident in some of these particular
comments which is translated over to the
reaction to the the New York Daily News
I'm going to talk about that in just one
second first let's talk about your suits
okay so the fact is that the suit you
are wearing right now you look like your
schlump okay I know you're at the office
and you think you look like you don't
you look like a schlump the reason I
know you look like there slump is
because you got that suit off the rack
didn't you you went down to the local
suit warehouse and then you picked up
the front of the thing you thought was
gonna fit you and now it looks like
you're wearing a burlap sack with a
couple of buttons on it okay what you
really need is a custom-made suit like a
suit that is made made to order from
enzo Chino Indo chinos the world's
largest maids amesh mejor menswear
company they've been featured in major
publications including GQ Forbes and
Fast Company they make suits and shirts
made to your exact measurements for a
fantastic fit guys love the wide
selections of high-quality fabrics you
can personalize all the details
including Europe you lapel lining
monogrammed you can either visit a
showroom or you can shop online at endo
Chino comm you pick your fabric you
choose your customizations you submit
your measurements and then you just wait
for your custom suit to arrive in just a
few weeks I've been to their showroom
over here in Beverly Hills and it really
is awesome you feel like James Bond
walking in there they let you pick the
fabric they fit you out they let you
pick all the various accoutrements that
have to do with the suit it's pretty
awesome
and right now my listeners can get any
premium Indo Chino suit for just 379
bucks at ENSO chinos calm when you enter
promo code Shapiro's at checkout that's
50% off the regular price for a made to
measure premium suit shipping is indeed
free Indo Chino kaam promo code
Shapiro's for any premium suit just 379
bucks and free shipping it's an
incredible deal for a suit that's gonna
fit you better than anything off the
rack ever could to stop looking as
though you're wearing a sack cloth go
get a suit that fits you and look snazzy
into Chino kaam promo code Shapiro and
you get that special deal ok so what I
guess when you look at president Trump's
trade policy and then you look at the
Democrats response to President Trump on
immigration there's a bigger message
that comes out from it as much as I
dislike president Trump's trade policy
and I do I think it's garbage
I think the president Trump doesn't
understand basic economics when it comes
to trade I think has a bizarre version
of how trade deficits actually work I
think this is likely to be harmful to
his account to the economy that he is
president during I don't like using the
phrase his economy cuz I don't think the
president runs the economy but the
economy over which he presides I think
it's going to hurt him to pursue this
policy with that said if you have to
contrast president Trump's apparent like
for sort of the manufacturing base and
the people in the middle of the country
what the Democrats dislike for those
people there's a reason that President
Trump won Wisconsin and Michigan and
Pennsylvania and Ohio going away there's
a reason that he did that and the reason
that he that is a feeling of sympathy
for these workers now I think the tariff
policy he's pursuing hurts a lot of
those workers and I think the president
ought to understand that I think he's
gonna lose votes in these states with
his tariff policy but it's pretty clear
that the president's heart is with a lot
of those people even if the policy he's
pursuing doesn't actually end with with
benefit to those particular folks the
same is not true of a lot of the folks
in our media how do I know this because
take a look at the reaction to the to
the failing New York Daily News okay so
the New York Daily News is having some
serious problems the presidents of the
United States always likes to say the
failing New York Times this the failing
New York Times that the reality is that
there is one major newspaper that is
failing in New York and it is the New
York Daily News the New York Daily News
decided they were going to cut 50% of
their editorial team they announced this
on Monday they sent a letter to their
entire staff they said we're reducing
today the size of the editorial team by
approximately 50% and refocusing much of
our talents on breaking news especially
in areas of crime civil justice and
public responsibility this is according
to trunk which is the parent company the
editor in chief with enemy Jim Ritchie
tweeted out his disappointment he said
if you hate democracy and think local
governments should operate unchecked and
in the dark then today is a good day for
you because that's clearly what the
parent company was thinking they weren't
thinking about the profit margins they
were thinking how do we make room for
local government to operate in the dark
and unchecked let's fire half our staff
that's probably what was going on at
trunk but the part that's really telling
is the reaction from all of these
leftist politicians in New York State so
a bunch of journalists get fired over
the New York Daily News and it's kind of
amazing how these politicians react so
here's how the politicians react Bill
DeBlasio is the New York mayor and he
says quote
it's no secret that I've disagreed with
the newt with the Daily News from time
to time but trunks greedy decision to
gut the newsroom is bad for government
and a disaster for New York City
trunks should sell the paper to someone
committed to local journalism and
keeping reporters on the beat well
thanks for your advice communist mayor
of New York who's never owned a business
really really appreciate that and then
Andrew Cuomo also issued a statement so
the block of wood known as the governor
of New York he issued a statement as
well again mostly amazing the blocks of
wood can become animate and issue
statements like this but I guess you
know anything is possible in today's
world he identifies as a human the Daily
News now owned by trunk Inc is
apparently firing a major portion of
their reporting staffs as the governor
this will undoubtedly devastate many
households and hurt an important New
York institution and one of our nation's
journalism Giants whether do I think
that Andrew Cuomo to react the same way
of Fox News fired half its staff I have
some doubts
since these layoffs were made without
notifying the state or asking for
assistance this is a free country when
is the last time if I fire someone at
this company I don't actually have to
notify Jerry Brown the governor of the
state of California first of all I
assume Jerry Brown be happy if people if
we lost employees at the Daily wire but
that in itself is a bizarre statement
then he says my father as governor came
to the aid of the New York Post when it
faced difficult financial times even
though the post represented an opposing
active partisan interest my father
understood the value of a robust Free
Press so do i purge trunk to reconsider
this drastic move and stand ready to
work with them to avert this disaster I
understand that large corporations often
only see profit and dividends as the
bottom line well that's how they got to
be large corporations if you don't see
profit as a bottom line then that's
because you're bad at business says but
in New York we also calculate loss of an
important institution loss of jobs and
the impact of families affected I hope
trunk does the same and recalculates its
decision New York State stands ready to
help first of all let me point out the
conflict between the editor-in-chief of
the New York Daily News saying if you
want heavier scrutiny on government what
happened today is terrible and then the
government saying will help you rehire
all those reporters do you think maybe
those reporters might go easy on
Governor Cuomo if Governor Cuomo is the
person who gets them rehired at the New
York Daily News you think maybe a
corrupt relationship between the
government in the press is probably a
bad idea but that's really not the point
that I'm seeking to make the point I'm
seeking to make is that the level of
outrage over the firing of these
journalists is wildly outsized there are
industries in the United States where
people
have lost their job they're talking
about dying industry towns we're talking
about production factories that existed
in the Rust Belt that have gone empty
they've turned into ghost towns and
there are those of us who are
free-market people who say you know
there are certain things that just
happened under a capitalist system
Joseph Schumpeter called it creative
destruction where every time there's a
new technological development certain
people in certain industries lose jobs
and we have to try and grease the skids
so that they can get new jobs in a
different industry or move out of those
dying towns right we have to do
something to help those people move out
of dyeing industry but that's just the
way the economy works but there are a
bunch of people in the press who just
ignore those people completely who sort
of have scorn for all those people who
are working in factory towns one of
these rubes who voted for Donald Trump
he's stupid rubes voted for Donald Trump
don't they understand how the economy
works don't they understand creative
destruction don't they understand that
the economy moves on and these are low
IQ idiot plumbers showing their butt
cracks
you know it don't they under then when
it's journalists then the world ends
right when it's journalists then we all
have to cry about it we have to deep
tears pity rage now the thing is that
the journalistic industry is actually
not in all that much trouble the New
York Times is doing fine The Wall Street
Journal is doing fine it's just that
everybody is moving over to a
subscription basis online as opposed to
free online content the New York Daily
News thought that they could cover for a
bad press strategy and a bad business
strategy by just printing nasty covers
about President Trump incessantly they
thought that was going to raise their
profile and their circulation it did not
but because they made a bunch of bad
decisions they laid off a bunch of
people but it is indicative of a certain
self-centeredness that exists on the
coast and in particular industries that
journalists jobs are more important than
the rest of your jobs that somehow these
journalists losing their jobs is a
tragedy for the country but the factory
worker in the center of the country
losing his job is just fine now my view
on this is that anybody who loses a job
that's a sad thing but we have to
determine whether that is a free-market
force at play and whether we can help
those people out on the back end but
without actually regulating all of these
other industries into into sort of
subservience to keeping lacking
industries alive but the but the fact
that there is this dichotomy in the
cultural attitude toward various jobs I
think is very telling and one of the
reasons the President of the United
States continues to be very successful
there's a feeling people too
York Daily News don't care very much
about you if you're in Ohio and the
president does even if the policy the
president is pursuing on trade is just
not correct
okay now meanwhile don't talk a little
bit about something that nikki Haley did
last night that I think is really
spectacular so president Trump's
ambassador to the UN nikki Haley did
something that is is quite great she's
speaking to a bunch of high schoolers at
the at the TP USA at the turning point
USA High School Leadership Summit and
she spoke specifically about owning the
libs now we'll talk about this in just a
second first I want to tell you about
what happens if you experience a
disaster there's an emergency what is
your first impulse okay here in
California we are now experiencing a
massive heat wave and the government is
telling us we should turn off our air
conditioner and lights which is just not
going to happen but if all the lights go
out if the air conditioner should go out
if all the food in your fridge starts to
spoil and suddenly all of the grocery
shelves are empty because everybody's
running out to try and replenish what
are you gonna do that and well one of
the ways that you can help kind of
militate against all of this is trusting
the folks at my Patriots supply for food
storage you should have some food in
your home and emergency food supply and
it's time free to go out and make it
happen right now right now each person
in your household should get a two-week
emergency food supply from my Patriot
supply these food kits are only 67 bucks
right now again this is not because
we're prepping for the apocalypse or
anything it's because there are times
when natural disasters hit there are
times when the police can't get to you
there are times when first responders
can't get to you or emergency aid and
it's just worthwhile there's an
earthquake and you need to be in your
house for 24 hours without being able to
go to the grocery store you want to make
sure that you have taken care of and for
relatively cheap you can make that
happen with the two-week emergency food
supply from my Patriot supply it's eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen go to my special website
prepare with been calm let's prepare
with Ben comm 888 803 1413 the food
lasts up to 25 years in storage and the
meals come packed in a rugged slimline
tote as well only 67 bucks rest easier
tonight knowing you're prepared again
that's 888 803 1413 prepare with Ben
comprehend calm again
eight eight eight eight o 314 at 13 okay
so nikki Haley US ambassador to the UN
and my spirit animal as I had suggested
before I'm a big nikki Haley fan she
also happens to be absolutely charming
in person and she spoke yesterday at the
turning point USA event in Washington DC
and I've spoken at many turning-point
USA events and it's filled with great
kids who really want to help push
America in a more conservative direction
I mean these are really motivating kids
one of the things that's become very
common among the younger said and I know
because I'm still one of the younger set
is that is this this notion then what we
ought to do here and the conservative
movement is own the libs if you've ever
been on Twitter this is all we talk
about all day long is owning the lids
and here at the Daily wire we are not
averse to owning the libs right we have
this the leftist here is hot or cold
tumblr and it comes free with your
membership for 99 bucks a year right we
need the whole point of the left is
tears tumblr is that we own lives okay
but the thing is and when you're going
to own the lives meaning own the
Liberals when you when you are worried
about owning the web's you actually
ought to own the lives by purchasing
them in a fair market rate and the way
that you do this is by actually making a
good argument convincing them right that
is the way that you own the lives and
nikki Haley understands this
unfortunately a lot of folks in sort of
conservative circles think that
triggering the libs is the same as
owning the libs triggering the legs is
not in fact owning the lives you can
take off people on the left very very
easily all you have to do is say
something basically factual about men
and women and people on the left hand
very very upset that's fine but
triggering people on the left you can do
that just by being a jerk as well and I
think it's very important to recognize
that the way that you win people over is
not always by being a jerk so Nikki
Haley was speaking at CPUSA and she said
raise your hands if you've ever posted
anything online to quote-unquote on libs
and everybody raised their hand because
this is the thing that you do on Twitter
and Facebook and then Nikki said I know
that it's fun and then it can feel good
but step back and think about what
you're accomplishing when you do this
are you persuading anyone who are you
persuading we've all been guilty of it
at some point or another but this kind
of speech isn't leadership it's the
exact opposite
real leadership is about persuasion it's
about movement it's about bringing
people around to your point of view not
by shouting them down but by showing
them how it is in their best interest to
see things the way that you do not only
do I think that that message is
eminently correct I said basically the
same thing at a teepee USA event just a
few weeks ago at the Young Women's
Leadership Summit but I think that we
ought to here on the right take Nikki
Haley's words to heart that doesn't mean
that we have to be weak and how we
promote our viewpoint not at all we
should be strong we should be powerful
we should be forward with how we promote
our viewpoint but we should also
recognize that just doing things to tick
off people on the left is not actually
going to win over the people in the
middle that you need
in order to win elections in order to
win the day the reason I bring this up
is because the presidents of the United
States yesterday decided that he was
going to think about pulling the
clearances of various Trump critics from
previous administration now here's the
thing about security clearances I think
that they should automatically expire
upon you leaving the government right
this is normally the way that it works
if you are a if you are fired like James
Comey was fired he lost his security
clearance I believe the same thing
happened with with James clapper as well
when you leave an administration very
often your security clearance goes away
with it but there are certain people who
are allowed to keep their security
clearance now just because you have a
security clearance doesn't mean that you
can access classified material it's not
like Susan Rice can stroll into the
White House any day of the week and then
just start accessing the computers and
looking up classified materials the idea
is that she retains her security
clearance in case somebody in the
government needs to talk with her or in
case she that there's another Democrat
who's elected and they want to bring her
back in so she doesn't have to be
cleared again she retains her security
clearance well there's a fair argument
to be made by the Trump administration
that security clearances should just go
away as soon as you no longer work for
the government if you have to redo it
later than we redo it later that's a
fair argument but instead it seems like
the Trump administration is talking
about removing security clearances from
various actors they perceive as bad and
many of whom are bad simply out of some
sort of retaliatory anger Sarah Huckabee
Sanders talked yesterday about a
president Trump was going to do with
regard to the clearance is exploring
these mechanisms to resume remove
security clearance because they've
politicized and in some cases actually
monetize their public service and their
security cleanse clearances and making
baseless accusations of improper contact
with Russia or being influenced by
Russia against the president is
extremely inappropriate so what that
sounds like is Trump is simply removing
security clearances from anyone who has
one who has been critical of him with
regard to Russia and that's not good
stuff now again I think there's a case
to be made that if you actually think
that James clapper or Susan Rice are
using their security clearance to get
access to information that they are then
using to lie about on national
television first of all we probably
ought to discuss whether there's a legal
violation that is prosecutable by the
DOJ but if there is not then this sounds
like simple troller e now is that owning
the libs well ticked off a lot of people
yesterday I ticked off a lot of people
on the left so Adam Schiff who literally
has a pup
that is actually pitched at the CNN
headquarters is what he does all day
he's no longer a congress person he's a
congress person to name only and he
actually sits out there drinking from a
thermos and then he just waits outside
until they call him in for his latest
hit on CNN so Adam Schiff he says that
this is just like I authoritarian regime
so the libs have been in fact triggered
by President Trump and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders suggesting that we will punish
critics of the present by stripping them
of their security clearance that is not
what you've seen in democracy that is
exactly what you see in authoritarian
regimes okay it is not exactly what you
see in authoritarian regimes typically
an authoritarian regimes you arrest your
opponents you don't strip them of a
security clearance to which they have no
actual solid claim so shift is triggered
it's not just chef who's triggered CNN's
Gloria Borger was also quite triggered
here's what she had to say on CNN
yesterday look the president wants to
silence his critics period I just think
the precedent is sort of stunning and
petty small rude and and doesn't speak
well for for a President of the United
States who is supposed to be able to
handle his critics
okay so again triggering for Goering
everywhere and people on the right
celebrate this because when CNN is
triggered that means something good is
happening well sometimes that's true
sometimes it's true than when you
trigger CNN it's because something good
is happening the president has triggered
CNN before for a good reason and I've
pointed it out when he has done so the
question is whether this is actually
beneficial or whether this is just you
know trolling the troll Paul Ryan
Speaker of the House he was outgoing so
he can now speak some truths he says
that this is basically just president
from trolling people I think he's
trolling people honestly this is
something that's in the purview of the
executive branch I think some of these
people already lost their clearances
some people keep their clearances that's
something that the executive branch
deals with it's not really in our
purview you can see he's just really
annoyed at this point and honestly I'm
kind of with Paul Ryan here it is it is
one thing to pursue good policy that
happens to trigger people on the left to
take them off to own them it is another
thing simply to trigger them and then
assume that you have done something good
based on this reaction from the left
this is what you end up with in this
case is a pure reactionary policy on
both sides of the aisle and it's
happening on the left
- right the left will do stuff just to
trigger the right the left will say
things like let's abolish ice now how do
I know they're lying about abolishing
ice because they brought it up for a
vote right the Senate Mitch McConnell
cocaine Mitch he actually brought this
thing up for a vote so Democrats
proposed what if we just abolished ice
and Mitch McConnell was like let's do
that now let's put that up for a vote it
went down unanimously not a single
Democrat voted to abolish ice even
people like Kirsten Gillibrand who said
that they want to abolish ice why do
they say it then because they're
triggering the cons so on the one side
you have people triggering the libs on
the other side you have people
triggering the cons and at no point you
have anybody who's actually having a
real rational conversation now in just a
second I want to talk about what the
cost of that is why that stuff actually
matters cuz maybe it's all just fun and
games and listen on Twitter I do it too
right it is fun and games to a certain
extent I don't talk about the real cost
of this in terms of public policy in
just a second but for that you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire calm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
the rest of Daley wires content get the
rest of the show live the rest of Andrew
Clavin Stroh live the rest of Michael
Moses show live you get to be part of
our mail bags on Friday you get to go
fill out the VIP section and our big
events coming up in Dallas and Phoenix
go over to Daley wired.com slash events
to get those tickets which are going
fast and when you subscribe you get this
the very greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist here is hot or cold
tumblr triggering the libs but also
because we like to we don't actually
wanna on the lips okay we want to lease
them because if you honestly if you're
going to if you if you own the libs then
you actually have to take care and
maintenance of them if you lease the
libs then the good news is you can turn
them in every few years because there
are new cupholders right every every new
year's they update the cupholders and
then you can actually just leased them
and turn in one Lib for the next which
is actually a better deal so go check
that out right now also you can ensure
that that you get our Sunday specials
when you subscribe over at YouTube or
iTunes our latest Sunday specials with
an Eric Weinstein next week we actually
have on micro which should be awesome so
go check it out subscribe over there and
click the little bell so that you are
notified when a new video comes out we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so what is all of this triggering the
libs triggering the constant what does
it matter isn't it all just in good fun
well there are two reasons that it
matters reason number one when people
are very interested in triggering the
libs in triggering the Khans they're
also very interested in sometimes
sometimes going too far so there are
those of us who understand that a lot of
this is just jokey and in sort of gamey
and yes you want to fight the leftist
positions as hard as possible because
those positions are wrong and in some
cases are actually evil you want to
fight those positions as hard as you can
but that's not the same thing as I'm
just gonna say something to say
something because it made Whoopi
Goldberg man or whatever Whoopi Goldberg
is mad about a lot of stuff I don't have
to say much to get her mad if you're
focused solely and completely on making
the other side mad all the time then it
stands to reason that you're also going
to be more likely to want to do things
that cross the bounds of civility you're
more likely to want to destroy people's
lives based on giant nothing's for
example you're more likely to say well I
want a grand victory because the ends
justify the means after all I triggered
them and if I triggered them that means
I did something right well that doesn't
make for good dialogue also it is true
that it brings you to a certain sort of
crisis mentality right that the whole
triggering phenomenon basically assumes
the people on the other side of the
aisle are the worst that humanity has to
offer
so simply by dint of you making them
angry you've done something good and
done something right that you making
them angry is in and of itself an
achievable and easy goal and therefore
it's something that we should aim at but
what if it turns out that the stuff that
we're triggering each other over is
actually rather minor but the stuff we
spend most of our time agonizing over is
actually relatively unimportant the
reason I think about this is that you
know I live in Los Angeles and everybody
in my immediate vicinity everybody
within a nuclear blast radius of this
office is on the left and all of those
people invariably invariably think we're
living in a crisis scenario you look
around la people are living pretty good
I'm pretty high on the hog everybody has
a nice house
people have nice cars aside from the
mass number of homeless people brought
in by the left in the city which is a
serious problem
people are living pretty well okay
people are you can be born in the
society and expect to live a full eight
decades and then things are good things
are good and yet we think that
everything is a crisis because we think
everything is a crisis every headline
becomes an excuse to fight the daily
battle by triggering the other side but
what if the real crisis
that our society is facing our crises
that are much deeper than that crises of
for example entitlement spending that is
going to our ability to do
anything in the future crises of a of a
young population that is losing its
purpose amidst all of this internecine
warfare what if it turns out that our
broader issues at stake and serious
conversations are merited well if you're
too busy triggering the other side you
can't have those serious conversations
because it's more important to slander
the other side is something terrible
than it is to have conversations that
are actually productive you know it's
it's been very telling I think the last
couple of weeks now I try to make a
point as much as I enjoy triggering the
occasional Lib and I do have a stock of
libs in my garage I mean it's sort of
like season 2 of The Walking Dead I
actually have in my garage a bunch of
libs you just sort of wander around in
there because I own many of them but you
know when when you one of the things
I've been trying to do and I've been
really this is not new I've been trying
to this since law school
is have substantive conversations with
people on the left the reason I want to
have the substance of conversations is
because it at least clarifies where we
stand in where the real rifts in our
society are going to be when it comes to
solving these serious and deep issues
and if we can't have those conversations
then what we end up doing is trying to
simply destroy each other for purposes
of the latest news cycle and that means
making people lose their jobs and it
means destroying people's careers and it
means going back through everybody's old
tweets and destroying them one by one
all right this is it this is what it
means it becomes a war we treat it like
a war guess what America is not actually
at war I know that a lot of folks on the
right who want to say that we're at
civil war there is an ideological battle
that is going on and it is meaningful
and it is deep but it is not the
conversation that we are having today
the conversation we're having today is
how angry are you at X and X invariably
something stupid and something small and
something petty and something worthless
there are real societal issues that
require us to have real societal
discussions that cannot be happening
that it's not going to happen if all we
worry about today is winning that
winning this particular Battle of the
headlines and that's not to say again
that we don't fight that battle of the
headlines but we fight it in good faith
in good spirits we fight it with a smile
on our face we don't fight it with this
kind of sour outrage and this vicious
glee in oh my gosh the other guy got
really really really really mad if you
don't like it on the left you shouldn't
like it on the right and I promise you
you don't like it on the left and when
you see people on the Left who are
penalty suggesting that the presidents
in the pocket of the Russians you're
angry aren't you you should be angry
because that's unbaked they don't
actually have evidence for that and
they're doing this to win the headline
of the day how many people on the left
honestly believe that the presidents of
the United States is in the pay of the
Russians and that we're being run by
Russia how many people actually believe
that and how many people believe that
because our tribal need to own the other
is is too strong how many people
actually believe that folks on the right
are truly deeply evil they don't believe
it about members of their own family
they don't believe it about people they
know on the other side of the aisle they
just believe that this sort of other
that's out there is truly terrible and
social media exacerbates this because
you get to hide behind your computer
screen all day you get to hide behind
your phone screen you get to pretend
that you're somebody that you're not you
say things to people on Twitter that
you'd never say to anybody in real life
louis c.k the the comic who no longer
gets to work louis c.k has a very funny
routine about how people are in their
cars when we suggest is that you scream
things at people in your car that you
would never say to them in an elevator
and if you're in a car and somebody cuts
you off in traffic you will curse a blue
streak you'll say things like I hope you
die
or as if you're in an elevator and
somebody brushed up next to you wouldn't
turn to that person right in your
physical I hope you die right you just
wouldn't do that social media does that
to people because you feel a certain
level of disconnect you can always turn
off the social media and it goes away
but here's the thing the problems that
creates in the country do not go away
and that's why nikki Haley is right we
ought to be operating in good faith and
we ought to be a lot less focused on
troller e and a lot more focused on
solving substantive issues now speaking
of substantive issues I want to talk
about a substantive issue that very few
people are going to talk about today and
that is that the New York Times has a
long piece about childless women and men
this is a substantive issue because
there are just too many people in
American society who are not having
children I know I'm popular viewpoint
with the left this is a true thing I'm
going to say that is going to trigger
the webs by virtue of it being true
Americans are not having enough children
we're not having enough children to
support our giant social welfare state
we're also not having enough children
just generally because we're replacing
ourselves at barely replacement rates
Europe is dying Europe is falling apart
the reason Europe is reliant on mass
immigration from the Middle East is
because they don't have enough people to
actually do the jobs the United States
is falling into the same trap why
because people have found meaning not in
what is the future hold and building a
better future but in this sort of
self-obsession
how can I live a more
satisfying personal life so the New York
Times is this fawning article about a
bunch of old people who don't have kids
now you might think that that's sad a
there are kids to visit them that have
grandkids to visit them and in fact
there's a picture leading this piece of
for old people sitting on a bench
looking out into the ocean right which
is really depressing just in it's sort
of context where you put a child in that
photo and suddenly it's charming but
without a child just looks like a bunch
of old people that are soon gonna turn
into tombstones that's essentially what
it looks like and here's what the
article says the vast majority of
American women have children yet fewer
women are deciding to become mothers the
fertility rate is at a record low when
we ask people who don't plan to have
children about the reasons for an
article in the upshot the top answers or
the desire for more leisure time the
need to find a partner and the inability
to afford child care many women said
motherhood had become more of a choice
and they were choosing to forego it
whether for whether for personal or
economic reasons in response to that
article and related one about a woman
who was happily child free we heard from
many older childless women and some
older childless men reflecting on their
lives without children many celebrated
their decision some wondered what might
have been others said they had moved
from feeling heartbroken to feeling
grateful okay now let's just face a
basic fact about humanity okay a basic
fact about humanity you will always
justify the decisions you made it's very
rare to find human beings who look at
the decisions they've made in their life
and said you know what really botched
that one that was a mistake
I think the first step toward becoming a
better human being and saying I made a
mistake and maybe I can do better but
people have a real stake in doubling
down on the stuff that they've already
done but here are some of the comments
Joanne from Georgia she is 62 over my
life of 62 years I've gone from being
heartbroken to relieved to proud that I
never had children why would you be
proud that you never had children what
sort of what sort of contribution to
society have you made by not generating
a second generation that's one thing if
you obviously can't have children few
have said that sort of trouble but to
choose not to have children is an
inherently selfish act again this is
very controversial proposition in
today's day and age the reason it is a
selfish act is because you are you are
voluntarily disconnecting yourself from
the future of the human species you no
longer have a stake in what happens next
the world stops turning the moment you
die once you have kids you start
realizing that your decisions mean
something more nothing changes human
beings more than having children nothing
makes you wreaths
the decisions that you've made in your
life more than having children and
deciding what to pass on to those kids
nothing makes you care more about
building a better society than having
children nothing makes you more
protective of the things that we have
that are good than having children and
when you sacrifice all that because hey
I had a good time and my kids weren't a
pain in the ass at least said enough to
deal with with little Timmy's drug
problem when he was 16 yes having kids
is a risk but it's that risk that not
only makes life worth living it makes
civilization worth preserving hey Carson
from from River Heights he's 66 she's 66
she says I'm a 66 year old woman who
chose not to have children and I've
never regretted it for a minute friends
lovers professional colleagues siblings
nieces and nephews neighbors and other
people can be constants in a person's
life too right that means that you are
basically mooching off of someone else's
kids implying that women who don't have
children are doomed to loneliness as
ignorant no it's not by poll data it is
certainly not ignorant the vast majority
of women want to have kids and they want
to have kids for a reason and just
because human beings have an enormous
capacity for self-deception and may want
to suggest to themselves that everything
is hunky-dory when they're 60 years old
living at home with no one else there
you know in a house by themselves with
no kids yeah good luck with that good
luck with that and then the fact that
New York Times is pushing this is pretty
telling retired and loved it from the
Oregon coast I'm retired woman 66 he
never had children I went to college on
the GI Bill dan always works a
white-collar job women like me were
considered oddities when I was in my 20s
and through and through my 40s instead
of having kids I spend time traveling
owning my own home and doing very
fulfilling volunteer work I was
fortunate to be able to retire at 65
I've never rented being travelers this
is fine the real question is why is the
New York Times actually pushing this and
the answer is because the New York Times
believes that this inherently
self-absorbed culture is something good
for the country this is something we
need to talk about how do we instill a
culture of purpose and meaning again in
people that they want to contribute to
the next generation and that they
actually want to be part of the great
chain of history that leads backward
toward a time when people did not live
in prosperity and decency with with
safety for their children toward a time
when people will live in ever-increasing
prosperity and decency with a sense of
meaning for their kids those are the
conversations we need to be having and
that's not going to be happening if we
are so focused on the triggering of the
Libs okay all that stuff's just not that
important okay time forward things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things I like tennis I've been doing
jazz all week which is to say yesterday
we're doing another piece of jazz today
Ella Fitzgerald of course one of the
great jazz singers of all time so my
grandfather guy would call Papa he he
was a jazz drummer so my dad is Janice
pianist my grandfather was a jazz
drummer sort of in his spare time and he
used to go down to a club where Ella
Fitzgerald would sing and he would bring
her corned beef sandwiches right before
she would perform actually and an Ella
Fitzgerald is considered by many
probably most to be the greatest jazz
singer who ever lived at least on the
female side of the ow here is a here's
Ella Fitzgerald is from her album Ella
in Hollywood I've got the world on a
string
[Music]
what a world
the biggest problem with playing Ella
Fitzgerald is you don't actually want to
stop playing Ella Fitzgerald
she's just terrific first-rate
first-rate musician and beautiful voice
yeah she's just great okay now let's go
to a bunch of stuff that I hate because
now I'm in a good mood I got to put
myself back in a bad mood as you know I
have a rule on the show I cannot end the
show none of the mood so let's do some
things that I hate so we begin with the
story of a Texas waiter this Texas
waiter decided that he was going to tell
everyone that there is a racist message
on a receipt okay this guy his name is
Khalil Cavill a 20 year old server for
salt grass steakhouse in Odessa and he
claimed in a post on Facebook that a
customer had left a racist note on a
receipt the post along with a photo of
the receipt quickly went viral it said
we don't tip terrorists cavil claimed
the message had left him sick to his
stomach he said the experience tested
his faith but then he added that he
wanted to let it inspire him to change
the world okay now I will give you three
guesses as to whether this receipt was
fake oh you got it on the first try okay
here is a basic rule of thumb whenever
anybody posts a receipt it's fake yeah
unless did somebody giving a giant tip
okay if it's something bad that somebody
wrote under-seat no one writes nasty
things on receipts as a general rule do
you know anyone who's ever done that I
never have okay I like really the
nastiest thing that I've ever done to
any sort of waiter or waitress is under
tip them if the service was really
really poor this is my grandfather's
thing also when he wasn't bringing in
corned beef sandwiches to to Ella
Fitzgerald if so if the service is
really poor and he thought the waitress
juror could leave them with a nickel tip
just to just to show them up I don't
actually do that I might end to over tip
because these people are working really
really hard but it's amazing how the
entire media will fall for these stories
time after time
oh my gosh we don't know who did it but
somebody wrote on the bottom of receipt
we don't tip terrorists do we have any
verification nodes we know who didn't
know but we know that the receipt is
real how do we know the receipt is real
because right because America's racist
that's the answer the answer is because
they think America's racist and
therefore the tip the the receipt has to
be real
once again this receipt was not in fact
real it's just a bunch of stupid okay
other things that I hate so this is a
crazy story so there's a
a shooting in Florida a guy named
Michael dredge gunned down
Marquis McLaughlin his 28 year old
father of three McLaughlin is black
Jessica is white and there is some video
that was shown on Good Morning America
it's kind of disturbing so if you don't
want to see it then then don't watch but
basically what the video is going to
show is that this guide rezku walked out
to a car and he apparently started
berating McLaughlin's girlfriend outside
the store he yelled at her for parking
in the handicapped space without a
permit so he was the the do-gooder who
was going to virtue signal by telling
these people to get out of the handicap
spot and instead of just walking by and
saying you know miss do you mind moving
this or in a handicap spot first of all
their spaces open in the parking lot
like it's in the video so it's bad to
park in a handicap spot but it does not
justify what happens next
Michael dredge qey tells this lady to
get out of the handicap spot and then it
turns into a shouting match her
boyfriend comes he out of the store and
it appears that this guy's yelling at
his girlfriend and so he pushes the guy
down and then what happens next is that
the guy pulls out a gun and points it at
the at the guy who just pushed him down
and the the person who pushed him down
McLaughlin he starts to back off a
little bit and then Drago shoots the guy
in the chest and kills him so here's
what here's what the video looks like
it's really disturbing was sitting in
her boyfriend's idling car when she says
47 year-old Michael dredge chica
approached to tell her that she
illegally parked in a handicapped spot
you can see McLaughlin
the store he sees and hears the argument
runs over and pushes dredge go to the
ground but that's when the irreversible
happens dredge qey takes out a gun and
shoots McLaughlin McLaughlin holding his
chest runs back into the store Jacobs
and the children watching from the car
he collapsed in front of my son and
within 30 minutes he was gone okay now
this is not now the reason that's nuts
is because they decided not to charge
the shooter and they decided not to
charge the guy the reason they decided
not to charge the guy is because they
invoked the Florida Stand Your Ground
law that is crazy
okay the stay on your ground law does
not say that you get to shoot anybody
who pushes you down on the floor now if
he'd taken out the gun and threatened
the guy with it the guy backed off and
then he'd call the police or something
then we're not talking about the same
thing he shot a guy to death after being
pushed to the ground the standard ground
law does not actually say that and this
is the
that's a little bit crazy is the fact
that the police decided not to charge
him based on this Mis invocation of the
standard grandma standard ground law
there has to be a deadly threat to you
and then you are allowed to stand your
ground now the media routinely
mist-covered the standard ground law so
they said that for example in the
Trayvon Martin case stand your ground
was was implicated stand your ground was
not implicated in the Trayvon Martin
case because Trayvon Martin was was shot
in self-defense according to the jury by
George Zimmerman he was having his head
pounded against the ground by according
to witness testimony and forensic
evidence but that the standard ground
law actually was never actually invoked
by the defense in that case in this case
for the police to invoke stand your
ground to say that it's okay for this
guy to shoot this other guy who's
basically backing away when he pulls the
gun is just crazy and demonstrates how
the police sometimes get it wrong I do
not understand the logic behind this and
and I'm having some trouble
understanding it frankly okay so that
brings us to the end of our show we'll
be back here tomorrow with all of the
latest hopefully we won't be in a
full-fledged rage what with trade war by
the time that happens but we'll find out
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing